i get botox it's literally a toxin that  freezes your muscle a bit so i wouldn't  say it's  something to do that's healthy but i  started getting it right here when i was  23. i'd been  chronically horribly depressed for my  entire life and i had these  frown lines that were just crazy and it  used to be my go-to expression which was  like if i was thinking about something  i'd frown and at one point my mom was  like you should get botox because it  might like relax your forehead and i got  botox and it was  such a relief it was such a relief to  not be glaring all the time which i'm  sure affects your serotonin levels but i  mean i'm 30 now so yeah i get botox and  it doesn't flare up my autoimmunity so  i'm happy with it